hello everybody and welcome to awesome
comics your one-stop shop for everything
comic book entertainment I'm your host
Walter Bernays II act how's it going
everybody we filmed our first two
episodes a few weeks ago I hope you've
enjoyed that Batman vs Superman and
Marvel's daredevil season 2 now we're
gonna move on to our favorite DC
live-action movies it's a hot topic now
with venom V Superman out there some
people are thinking Bambi Superman is
their favorite live-action DC movie but
spoiler that's not any emergent sorry
sorry about you know I'm happenin before
we do the introductions I wanted to pose
a couple questions to you guys our
audience I want to know we all want to
know what do you guys want to see
covered on the show we're still pretty
young here we're trying to see what
works and what doesn't so we want to
hear from you guys out there what do you
want to see us cover is it more movie
type news TV news do you want to see us
cover more comic book type news we're
gonna be talking about comics today but
you want to see more of the news type
stuff with comic books let us know in
the comments I'm sure you will and also
we're thinking about making episodes a
little bit longer so what would you be
comfortable with watching are you okay
with like half-hour episodes 45 minute
episodes hour episodes let us know we
could talk all day we could talk all day
seriously they'd be actually a lot
easier live stream it all day yeah
absolutely let us know in the comments
below okay so I'm gonna introduce our
panel for today we're gonna go over here
and let you introduce yourself hey
everyone I am Beth elder King I am coast
of shark jumping on Channel awesome and
happy to be here on awesome comics so
everything's awesome really all right
hey I oh no wait here I'm back from the
last couple episodes happy to be back
telling you my favorite pick same here
Brian Porter and glad to be back and
co-host on awesome comics are you ready
to talk about your favorite DC live
action be sure okay
alright ladies and gentleman this is
gonna be our own favorite DC live-action
movie I'm sure that there's a lot of you
out there oh you love this off the list
well let us know in the comments
no because I'm I'm sure that that's a
good movie to write so yeah we're gonna
get to our pics right now so I honor
your first what is your movie what's
your favorite DC live-action movie
favorite live-action movie Batman and
Robin wait no okay my favorite is Dark
Knight I know I'm not alone in that
because it is an amazing movie and just
happens to be my favorite everything
about it is good scores good actions
good casting is good character
development is good I like it it's just
like it it's great a lot of people love
the Dark Knight yeah it's a lot of their
favorite from the Nolan trilogy and
Heath Ledger as the Joker what do you
think of him
I remember the backlash he was getting
when it was first announced that he was
cast in it and I like Keith ledger so I
wasn't on the hate train but finally
when we saw his performance and he just
killed it yep killed it I mean he was
one of those actors that was always like
undersold people did could not get that
he actually could turn in a really good
performance so when people were
legitimately surprised I mean I was a
Heath Ledger fan right time I'm like
told you so yeah and that's one of those
things that now I think everyone cites
that as like well don't judge a book by
it's cover because I know you might not
like this casting choice but you never
know remember you didn't like Heath
Ledger as the Joker and then you ended
up loving him he had to stand up against
Jack Nicholson and that was that's a
tough person to beat up oh yeah right
the laughs the voice everything was just
so ingrained in us since we all I think
everyone in Jack Nicholson his his
personality is not too far off really
interesting to see like in 10 to 20
years who we consider to be the better
Joker because Heath Ledger's Joker was
really of the time we are really talking
about anarchy and you know political
revolutions and all that stuff so he was
really that back voice where as Jack
Nicholson had a different portrayal so
you know in 10 20 years I don't know who
we're gonna be liking more I like Heath
Ledger's performance too but I may feel
differently
it's more like he talks about it in in
the film he talks about being like a dog
on a chain he wouldn't know what he
would do if he was let loose and he the
Heath Ledger was able to just let it
loose yes right and let it go to the
point where now we have people trying to
jump the shark a little bit with their
Joker performances and bring dead rats
and oh yeah
I gotta say I find it really interesting
that we're talking about a Batman movie
yet we're barely talking about that man
he was so oversharing what yeah because
it kind of takes a backseat to the Joker
performance-wise and everything even
Christian Bale has come out recently and
said like you know what I was doing was
not as interesting as what Heath was
doing in the Dark Knight and he was kind
of overshadowed by that but I think in
Batman Begins he was driving the story
he was the centerpiece everything like
that he's more of just a big piece of
the puzzle in the Dark Knight he's not
really the focus and I think that's it's
kind of unfortunate because Batman
Begins set up everything so well for the
nolan universe we never hear anything
about the freakin arrows again like all
that stuff was set up so well i was
looking forward to the sequel and
obviously dark knight delivered but not
in the way that i thought I was going to
it's true no you're right yeah another
thing about Bale that I think was
lacking all three films for me he he
never really seemed like a detective he
never had that mentality a little a tiny
bit like okay yeah but he didn't have
that in mind that that near genius-level
intellect of just how he looks at
everything and he's so out of the box in
the comic comics with how he looks at
everything and how he figured stuff out
really show that video games - yeah he
investigates the games you kind of get a
glimpse in' and like we saw a little bit
of him like you know carving out the the
brick with the bullet in it and then
strapped in yeah extrapolating that like
that was cool
but like for the most part he just
seemed like he wasn't that smart and his
fighting style was way more it was
smaller low brawling and he was just a
brawling boxer and he just there was
none of that finesse for me but other
than that I really liked it okay
one of the nice things too is they kind
of give you a taste of two-faced without
being like here's a lot of CGI
guys they give you a little bit and they
don't overdo it which I kind of like so
yes he kind of takes a little bit more
of a backseat as a villain but they
don't like shove it in your face like oh
we got this really cool effect we want
to show it off they do and they like
keep it simple well we're gonna go on to
your pick for the best
live-action DC movie and it's another
banner movie which one is it Batman one
of the best Batman stories ever our
movies anyway it has one of the best
Batman actually I like I like Michael
Keaton better as Bruce Wayne than Batman
I think he was a really good Bruce Wayne
captured the fact that Batman does not
know how to be Bruce Wayne as the people
seized him that's his mask he is Batman
and Bruce Wayne is his alter ego yeah
and I think that he really captured that
because he was a little awkward in it he
just never felt natural in like being
Bruce Wayne and then when he puts on the
Batman suit obviously he's naturally so
he wants to be and all that stuff
and so I think he really captured Bruce
Wayne in that respect so he's definitely
my favorite Bruce Wayne of all time and
I love him as Batman he's not the best
but he is definitely up there I love
this suit I think the way it looks on
and it looks great even though he's very
rigid and you can tell I'm in a rubber
suit and but I think it's fantastic and
just um Tim Burton directing it it's
just phenomenal he captures Gotham
better than everybody else I've ever
totally agree I'm even though in the
Dark Knight series we see a lot of
Gotham and we see a lot of the Narrows
and this and that various aspects of
Gotham as a whole we he just doesn't
quite capture the dark grittiness that
is I think in a statement yeah and in
Batman is so gothic and it's just so
just it really fits the universe and
Burton style is totally mirrored in the
comics I think and then definitely
on-screen I think he he captured it so
well and then you take Danny Elfman of
Tim Burton it's like staple movies oh
yeah and then you have him do that score
when you when you blend those you know
Burton and Elfman together they already
have a rapport with each other and how
you know the music with the set design
what
I think it's just perfect for bat
minutes I think it's probably one of the
best scores of them and even though hans
zimmer was amazing in Dark Knight but
and then Jack Nicholson obviously is the
Joker about that do you like him better
see I don't answer the question corner
yes or no do you like Jack Nicholson's
Joker better than Heath Ledger's Joker
yes and no there are two very different
jokers you've got the Clown Prince of
which one you like better
I can't a because I read a cop-out
answer no it's not matter you must have
friends
no Jack Nicholson is very much the Clown
Prince of Crime he's got the gangster
aspect to it he's a very classic Joker
like that's like who I imagine as the
Joker when I see the Joker in the comic
and I feel really ridiculous when I saw
some comics and we that's up to 89
that's pretty much what we had seen so
so far and I think he really fits that
Joker but then Heath Ledger's Joker I
mean that guy is all about the anarchy
he's the psycho killer and I think
you've got the the gangster and then the
anarchist and I think there's such
different types of Joker's you can't put
them against each other and just who's
better who did it better the fact that
Batman 89 pay and Batman Returns paved
the way for batman the animated
adventures and how that movie was or
that TV show was even brought about like
how dark batman 89 was and Batman B
Returns Batman The Adventures of Batman
was drawn on black paper serious like
they drew it on black paper and that
totally preserves how dark the series is
gonna be and then Gotham in the Batman
TV series was so reminiscent of Batman
89 on the movie we got this amazing
staple of anybody in our generations
Batman like you think of Batman in TV
series it's The Adventures of Batman
Batman the Animated Series like it
that's what it is you you think of
Batman's voice you don't think bail you
don't think that's a bad Fleck
you don't think
think of it you think kevin conroy you
think kevin conroy when i think that was
a batman yeah and when anytime I hear
Joker or read Joker in the comics fix
mark marks Hamill Mark Hamill so Thank
You Batman 89 for giving us batman the
animated adventures because that was the
pinnacle of supposed to have superman do
anyway I'll let me talk about this 1978
Christopher Reeve movie directed by
Richard Donner in my opinion the best DC
live-action movie because one of the
main reasons is it started everything
this is the movie that really
kick-started the superhero genre back in
1978 and everything about it is epic
everything it's it's very much and they
say this an audio commentary they always
talk about it in documentaries it's very
much a three-act play because of the
first act is on Krypton and the sets in
the miniature work and everything on
Krypton is incredible like the crystal
look of Krypton in the fortress solitude
is still used in the Superman comics in
any iteration of Superman most of the
time it's that crystallized look and
that was created in this movie it's so
iconic the mystical effects just stand
the test of time absolutely yeah I mean
the blue screen flying effects I mean
you know you're in 78 but still all the
effects and everything like look great
still all the miniatures look great all
the sets look incredible and so much
workers went into just the design of
everything it's so beautiful and small
of all the shots you get of like wide
open plains and everything I mean the
look of The Daily Planet
all that is just freakin great they shot
this at the same time they were shooting
Superman too and they rushed to finish
one because of budgetary concerns and
they fired what your Diner from Superman
to which was the biggest mistake in the
Superman franchise ever I think they
brought on Richard Lester to finish him
ran two after the original was let out
it was very even more over-the-top
a bookie funny like Kofi champion and
Superman is campy it is oh not nearly as
much as like three and four and how they
went off the rails with that later they
did come out with Superman to the
Richard Donner cut later which I own and
is a superior look at Superman too with
different versions of scenes the stuff
that Richard Donner shot they actually
went back and reshot a bunch of scenes
that Richard Donner originally did with
Richard Lester and all those original
scenes are preserved and they're in the
movie even sometimes I have to use
screen tests because they weren't you
know they didn't get to film all of it
but it's like Richard Donner's version
of Superman is the most iconic version
Christopher Reeve Superman you can't
tell me that you can't still think of
like yeah he's like just the iconic hero
yes absolutely and he's the boy scout
absolutely has everything that Henry
Cavill lacks it's more the direction in
the direction of the story and the
writing and everything he's being made
dark and right and serious and you know
what if people like that that's fine but
for me I'm what I'm not I'm not
admittedly not the biggest Superman fan
sure but if I were to pick a Superman
that I like it's the one who just fully
embraces that he's just the big iconic
hero from space who's gonna come save us
all who will save a cat from a tree all
right he's the hopeful super it's fine
he's a whole word Superman he's the
correct way to portray the character in
my opinion he's not a multi weird guy a
hopeful person mopey Jesus he inspires
me he inspires us to reach our own
potential as human beings that's what
Superman's supposed to do with a real
Superman
is a little cheesy okay that's fine
Superman can be a little cheesy and
there is a way to modernly portray this
character I think that isn't the Snyder
gloom and doom interpretation with some
contemporary alterations Reeves Superman
could still work today if done the right
way if the core that character the
goodness and the inspiration that
character is still at the center he
could still work with like you know
making more things contemporary and
stuff putting in modern times it could
still work if you just give it a chance
I've seen it a home there's things that
happen around the world all the time
that's been
we know this but it's okay to have a
little bit of escapism and it's okay to
put a smile on your face just every
single time you walk out of a superhero
or a Superman movie theater or you watch
it at home
when those credits roll you need to be
smiling yes you need to be happy about
what you just saw with Superman and
there is none of that in the new movies
like you can have depth and still have
hope I think that kind of describes the
Dark Knight Batman 89 and I'm going with
V for Vendetta
from 2006 so V for Vendetta is beta is
it based on an alum more coming from the
1980s and it's all about a dystopian
future in Britain where it's in the
comic books it's fascism and in the
movie it's basically neoconservatism and
we have this character in a mask the Guy
Fawkes mask which is back here who is
basically causing chaos he's causing
anarchy because in the comic he wants to
just he wants Anarchy he wants absolute
chaos everywhere but in the movie he's
trying to give hope he's trying to tell
people that the government doesn't
control you you control the government
and that's what I really that's the
message I really love is that actually
while Alan Moore's version worked really
well for Margaret Thatcher politics in
the 1980s especially in yeah I mean in
Britain in the last you know Reagan
reflected in the u.s. this one works
really well for where we're at right now
like even now like I washed it 2016 it
still rings really true for the
experiences that we're having and it's
just it's deep and it leaves you feeling
good which is surprising considering it
is very violent there's a lot of
unpleasantness
yeah there's torture there's torture
that goes on for about 30 minutes good
guy though yes is the torture he does
the torture he has his reasons okay
that's one of the things that works
better in the comic book because he is
just trying to give it he's just trying
to bring anarchy so of course he would
torture his protagonist because he wants
her to be an anarchist but in the movie
it's a little bit more vague but it
still has the same ends it still gives
her hope she sees what it's like at the
bottom so that when she's out she can be
free mmm
we should mention I know everyone's
gonna be like it's vertigo yeah it's
vertigo but it's under the DC banner so
our going into it for a fun action film
you are not going to get that at all but
if you're going into it trying to take a
quote-unquote supernatural or superhero
glimpse at the ugly side of the world
that we live in right now I feel like
the Wachowski sisters did a great job at
that but I don't know I just um it just
doesn't it didn't leave me with anything
and I remember wanting to see it because
the trailers look good it looked like a
cool movie it's got an interesting
concept the guy fawkes he looks great
and he's fired anonymous yeah Hugo
Weaving although I I do remember that I
liked Hugo Weaving as that guy that kid
what was his name guy Vendetta
I don't know that was quite that did not
work in the movie that was like his big
introduction and it looks like this
sounds really silly on film like Hugo
Weaving from memorizing that and yeah he
was actually a last-minute substitute
they originally had another actor I
forget who it was but he was a couple
weeks in and the mask was too hard for
him he thought he couldn't emot-- so
Hugo Weaving actually stepped in and
took the role over and I what's up he
was like I got okay
and I thought Natalie Portman did a
great job too and I will say that she
her character was given a lot more
agency in the film
than in the comic in the comics she's a
16 year old who's prostituting herself
or failing to prostitute herself so I'm
like okay let's make her an adult let's
give her a little bit more to do she's a
TV station I'm good right okay well yeah
I mean that's a definitely
unconventional choice in terms of like
what we've picked but it's good to have
a ride so V for Vendetta
all right well right now what we're
gonna do we've you know our favorite
pics for DC movies and we wanted to get
at least one more person so our friend
Heather ruse went to graham cracker
comics in Wheaton Illinois to get a
couple thoughts from a few people over
there at a actual comic book shop so hey
guys it's Heather we're here at
graham-cracker comics in Wheaton and
we're gonna go see what people's
favorite DC movie is and see if they
like where the DC Universe is headed so
let's go
it's a middle-aged fat man who has let
himself go he's part of the little
Gotham series for all the kids who would
like to know what Batman looks like at
60 after he stops working out
I'm feeling very drawn to this book
right now maybe I shouldn't touch that
I'm here with Rick how you doing today
Rick good how are you
fantastic thank you for asking we have a
very important question for you what is
your favorite live-action DC movie as of
right now it's Batman vs Superman dawn
of Justice it's honestly the best
live-action Batman I've seen ever
and I love Man of Steel's so Henry
Cavill is fantastic and yeah I I'm also
one of the few people who love Jesse
Eisenberg he's totally playing Sheldon
from the Big Bang Theory but as an evil
guy I could care less about Justice
League as long as I could see that
wonderful movie so then how do you feel
about where the DC Universe is going
cinematically ah I like parts of it my
biggest problem is that Suicide Squad
looks horrific ly bad to me it's like
they're trying to make guardians of the
galaxy but they forgot like oh this is a
superhero movie we'll just put five guys
in leather costumes like the x-men
movies
I don't like cyborg so the fact that the
Terminator guy makes cyborg was okay and
I don't know why they miss cast flash so
horribly I really want DC movies to
succeed thank you very much for talking
with me today Rick personally my
favorite DC movie is the Dark Knight's I
don't think anything could ever be Heath
Ledger's Joker but you guys may have
made the wrong choice we'll see this has
been how their ruse at graham-cracker
comics in wheaton back to you guys in
the studio
ah Wolverine should be a female okay
thanks
right now we wanted to introduce a
little bit of a new set around the show
we're gonna do a little bit of a news
breakdown we're gonna try to keep this
short and quick
the first news piece on
the agenda here at The Killing Joke is
coming out with an animated movie no
idea the trailer came out little teaser
in the head a 10-minute behind the
scenes a little featurette for it I'm
super excited for it I'm excited to see
my Barbara Gordon I know that comes is
such a surprise I know the featurette
was amazing I love the featurette and
just all the background and how they did
the film and how they had you know
translate it from the comic to the
screen and how that was incredibly
difficult and it was hard to really
capture Bryan Bolin's like real essence
in the comic and how they kind of have
they tweaked it a little bit I know it's
not quite 100% of the comic but it's you
can't always get through that
no you can't get lucky like you are with
Frank Miller in the director
controversial part they showed little
scenes in the future and yeah I'm so
excited I can't wait to see it really
quick to the next news story it's Jackie
moving here I believe this has just been
confirmed from Warner Brothers that
Suicide Squad is going into reshoots to
make it fun yeah yeah yeah but a bunch
of cuddles thank you how much power
though a trailer can have yeah all of us
watching it can make it go back into
reshoots but also think Batman vs
Superman weighed heavily on that
decision as far as the fact that there
was no humor I don't know arias sources
were saying that they used all the jokes
in the killer everything that is a
problem with Hollywood right now but
that's something for a different day
stop using all your material in the
business right into the next thing note
so there are rumors about this I'm not
sure if it's true and they did kind of
go back on this a little bit there's
rumors that DC may be scaling black back
plans on more DC Universe movies because
of the massive drop-off at the box
office for Ben vs. Superman but I mean
they did just announce two new movies
for the DC slate they did announce what
those were they just came in release
dates maybe Batman
maybe I hope so any move the Wonder
Woman they moved up Wonder Woman three
weeks
I mean I'm curious why they moved it up
three
weeks is that weekend I had I was like
okay three weeks we got to move on to
the final news story this is the Walking
Dead finale was last Sunday port is the
only person who watches The Walking Dead
here I'm sorry okay
the episode itself was great negan's
entrance was awesome Jeffrey Dean Morgan
is fantastic actor and he delivered so
well with negan but the the frickin cut
away the last scene you see negan beaten
the out of someone in the head with
the bat loose ears my bad what they cut
away you can its from a perspective of
whoever's getting beat and you don't see
who it is so we've got six months to
wait we're not gonna find out until
freakin October and that is awful that
was a terrible choice and I know a lot
of fans were super pissed off about that
myself in kleenex season but we gotta
wrap it up I'm sorry you want these
episodes longer less no one may come on
I won't want to go really quick in the
pics of the week they tie into our
individual choices as for our favorite
DC live-action movies Beth I know that
you did a little bit different from our
caper I know digital you guys and now
I'm sure some people are gonna be like
what I read on my computer because I
have my computer everywhere and I have a
small apartment so I can't have the
plethora of comics in my exciting nation
so I am gonna recommend the original V
for Vendetta a comic book the reason
being is that the focus in it is much
different than the movie it focuses on
fascism versus anarchy instead of
neoconservatism versus liberalism and
you get different parallels between them
the representation of women is a little
bit more questionable in the comic book
so you just have to kind of take that
with a grain of salt but there is a lot
more ambiguity there's not as clear a
good guys there is in the film and
that's really that's something that's
something good to think about sure it
was a good read all right signing to the
Dark Knight would you pick I on Batman's
along Halloween oh yeah we've got the
two-face origin story we've got some
Joker in here we've got
good like the the main trio of Gordon
dent and Batman which is great giant
ears mm-hmm oh yeah his ears are like
there's some good stuff in here it's uh
it's like that crime drama feel that you
like it's it's very Godfather II you got
a lot of mob stuff give a look if you if
you like dark dark night I think this is
your best source material all right
Porter I brought some stuff for you you
brought some stuff this is for Batman 89
what is your picks
Batman mad love it's based heavily on
completely like ripped out of the series
Batman the Animated escape first the
animated series and I think this like I
know it's this is for the the show but
you can read this and think of Batman 89
the movie like or vice versa you can
totally have a feeling for either movie
or TV show form from this book and I
think that translates really well and
really showcases how awesome Batman 89
was it can translate into a children's
TV show and a comic book and still not
lose anything I think it's great it's a
great read to Mad Love it's Harley
Quinn's like origin and whatnot and it
is awesome it's great read
yes and terms for me Superman I picked a
couple the John Byrne first couple
issues for the Man of Steel after the
relaunch of the crisis on Infinite
Earths from 1986 John Byrne sort of
retooled Superman's origin story and
it's a really good read also I picked up
while heddes for a while but I decided
to show you guys Superman's secret
origin by Geoff Johns from a few years
ago these are really fun stories not
Jeff Jon's best work I mean it snapped
like it's night but it's really cool
it's got a different take on Superman's
origin story and they drew him Gary
Frank drew him to look just like
Christopher Reeve so that's pretty cool
ties into my movie I think but he won't
okay so go ahead and check out all these
books they're all fun read them I mean
here's it's kind of dark but it's okay
it's rivers and then readers
exactly got a serial killer so it's fine
okay where can we find you on Anna
you can find me on Twitter and Facebook
and they will be listed right here
Facebook as well it's under awesome
Porter facebook.com slash awesome Porter
it's got all my you know just you know
opinions on like comic book stuff
basically everything related to the show
so okay alright you can find shark
jumping on YouTube it's youtube.com
slash shark jumping show and of course I
am on Twitter at Beth alder Kane and you
can also find me on instagram at Beth
elder kin where I've been posting photos
of these awesome people so it's a
win-win yes it is you can find me at
awesome underscore Walter on Twitter and
I basically just post about what
everyone so if you like it you like it
that's fantastic alright everybody for
everyone here next week we're gonna be
talking about our favorite Marvel movies
not just Marvel Cinematic Universe any
kind of Marvel movie so make sure you
come back for that and until next week
I'm Walter pan a Z again we will see you
on the next page
you